relationships always bring up the most
crap you know the thought that you'd
have is like well they're they might
leave right like i don't want to scare
them off or leave but really the truth
is is that you're just saying
subconsciously i'd be thinking to myself
well that just means that uh like
subconsciously i think i'm not really
worth it remember these protect you so
when you express a boundary with a
partner what you're doing is you are
empowering yourself
to act like an adult in the relationship
instead of having there be land mines
all over the place emotionally where you
get triggered and withdraw when i was 19
i ended up in a really abusive
relationship
which i i now see is sort of like the
catalyst for my awakening in a way
there was at one point where he had
hurt me and i was in the bathroom had
locked myself in the bathroom
and i looked in the mirror and i could
hardly recognize myself but all of a
sudden it was as if the top of my head
opened up and just this message poured
in and it was just like
shalina you're gonna be speaking on
stage to women about this one day like
this is what you're meant to be doing um
when we get into things like betrayal or
relationships not working out and we go
back and we get really still your
initial intuitive hit
is spot on the problem is that you get
all this other stuff that starts to come
up that's a very powerful biochemistry
so you might have a for example a first
impression where your biochemistry is
like this guy's just like my abusive
father it feels like home but your
intuition is like nah girl this is toxic
shut up we're gonna we're gonna move
forward right because we're gonna this
is exciting and fun or whatever right
masculine
value
the masculine bout
is that i my consciousness
is free
you can feel
the the depth of my connection to the
infinite truth of life
in my body and in my in just in my aura
i guess if you want to use that word you
can feel it it's physical it's it's
tangible
um and so you can feel the depth in me
and when you feel that in me and you're
my romantic partner
chances are it's going to feel good
and so if you just let your body respond
with the energy that's wanting to come
through you
it's the feminine gift so the feminine
gift is the response of energy to
consciousness and depth
[Music]
right and then it becomes a dance then
like the more energy you bring the more
present he gets the more fierce he gets
the more you know
penetrated with his
gaze he gets the more attention more his
attention just comes like on you but you
know when we all see this we see this in
our most intimate relationships whatever
partnership
we have an intimate partnership in life
rarely do people grow at exactly the
same time in exactly the same direction
often one one will be the explorer
and more open-minded and the other
will be more content
with
what has been learned and discovered in
the past
and so the explorer may open new doors
and then the content one has to choose
do i want to grow and go through these
doors with my partner
more of us than than not sit on the more
codependent end of the spectrum if you
would have asked me a decade ago though
danica if i was codependent i would have
looked at you laughed said
not at all definitely next i knew what
codependency was a decade ago i just
didn't know how that it applied to me
so when i talk about it now i talk about
a much more expanded definition of it
because like i said i do believe a lot
of us are struggling with that in our
relationships for a lot of different
reasons essentially what it is though is
a blurring so i'm a person if we think
about me with like a little
kind of cell memory and around a circle
around yeah right so to be in a healthy
relationship i believe in
interdependence so there is a space like
we we are social creatures we benefit
from relationships relating with others
help even just from division of labor to
stress reduction we need relationships
right so i'll give you an example
so um
my husband recently came to me and
expressed what you would call a boundary
we have we live in an old farmhouse and
the garage is um like at the lower level
so you kind of pull in you can park up
top or you can pull around underneath to
the garage
and um
whenever we get packages you obviously
have boxes that arrive to the house
you have to carry them downstairs after
you unpack the boxes from amazon or
wherever in order to get them into the
recycling bins
well i have a habit of stacking up the
boxes empty boxes like a giant tank like
tango or whatever game it is
right at the top of the door to the
stairway to the basement
and for years i've done this and my
husband has never said anything
what he's done is he gets passive
aggressive
where there'll be 11 boxes there and
then he's like ripping the tape off and
like like angrily like slapping the
things down and i'm like why are you all
in that you know like or like throw the
things down the stairs and everything or
like pick them up in a huff and finally
he said to me
would you
please
take the boxes downstairs to the garage
so we talked about your initial
impression right it's like what part of
we are you are we talking about right if
we're talking about butterflies and
biochemistry you know that's not an
indicator of long-term relationship
health like just because you have a good
chemistry doesn't mean anything because
good chemistry is not what creates a
long-term relationship you can build a
good chemistry over time
because if you have a friendship first
if you have an emotional connection
first if you have emotional safety first
you can learn what other people the
person needs in terms of whatever their
buttons are that pushes their chemistry
a certain way um and sometimes initial
chemistry can just be like an automatic
failure trauma response from the past
and sometimes it's very healthy right so
there's no like right or wrong answer
but what you want to try to get at
instead of like what i tell people when
it comes to dating right it's like
if you're interested in someone or
pursuing somebody or you're kind of in
that in between phase you don't make a
move
i don't care one day two day three day
ten days however long whatever the
dating ex who cares about dating experts
and all that who cares until you're in a
state where you feel clear about what
you're gonna do and you're not operating
from like oh my god i need to respond or
butterflies right or any of that stuff
right
until you're like really clear on like
what you want to say and like it's
coming from like a really solid place do
not
respond okay like slow it down right
what's the rush right and i actually
think it's important in new
relationships to like have that
magnetism happen where you slow things
down because a lot of times it can be a
trauma response to rush into
relationship too fast and not pay
attention to the signals that your
body's giving you let's flip the roles
and
what would a woman do to
sort of initiate or start that energetic
exchange process
same rules
just let's just call the moment of blank
slate
like the moments of blank slate he could
be watching tv he could be cooking
dinner
he could be sitting outside
and the moment is this blank slate
and
so if you come to the moment and you
bring energy that occurs to his nervous
system as
enlivening nourishing
pleasurable energy
then you've now brought the energy to
the moment
right and he will likely
you know unless he's just totally
distracted he will likely
take a deep breath he won't even know he
did this
he'll look at you
right because you've now got his
attention and he'll take his awareness
literally his awareness his
consciousness and he'll place it on you
right and so you've you've now sparked
that moment just by right now who knows
it's your art right so it could be you
sit next to him you start twirling your
hair
it could be like what are you reading
right whatever it is it could be
you kind of sachet next to him and let
him feel your hips
it could be it could be anything it
could be just like you purr
at him
all of that is energy
and what i see and i mean i'd lead lots
of workshops and what i see is that men
men are craving energy
from the feminine craving craving
craving craving it's why they watch porn
it's why it's why they
you know it's why they get attracted to
certain kinds of women
[Music]
because they because in this
incredible feminist revolution which
again i'm a huge fan of y'all can't take
over the planet fast enough for me
but
there's a certain level of
energetic repression
that happened culturally if you know
what i mean
and so women are less apt to reveal the
truth of their heart they're less
they're more fearful to reveal
their kind of giddiness or their
pleasure or their you know some of it's
because men have not treated them well
and that's totally legit
but in a in a romantic relationship that
energy
is the gift it's like it's literally
like food for his heart and this might
sound silly but it's a lot of us that
don't know how we want to spend our time
and maybe look to someone else or worry
about the effects of how i want to spend
my time how that would affect someone
else so like if i have a partner right i
feel like i always have to check in what
are we doing saturday partner instead of
well saturday i want to do this and it's
okay partner if you don't want to do
this with me so it can be anything from
behaviors like what i want to do how i
want to spend my time to thoughts right
a separation where i can allow you to
have separate beliefs i can have
separate beliefs a lot of times families
this is where this originates my family
we had mantras we had things that the
lapera's believed this is what we
believe as a unit with no space for well
maybe nicole or you know my sister over
here believes differently
and then feelings and i think this is
the area where when i said that
catch-all we all are a little
co-dependent i think a lot of us connect
our feelings with someone else's meaning
i it's like i talk about it like a
roller coaster right so where i'm
reacting emotionally to the emotions
everyone else is having in the world to
what they think of me so that's another
barrier that we want to put into place
where i can have my feelings because
we're all different things are going to
affect me differently than they affect
you and again back to that healthy
relationship i think there needs to be
space where i can have feelings that
might be separate from other people's
and where i don't gain my value
based on how i feel about myself based
on other people what you might want to
call like an unconscious or a
conventional relationship versus a
conscious relationship
is that in a conventional relationship
if you do something to hurt me
my first instinct is to react to blame
you to demonize you
and to put all of the blame on you
and and then to do whatever my coping
mechanism is sure so okay so that could
be trying to convince you to love me
deeper because i have this wound in me
that needs validation it could be to
ghost you because you know once you've
hurt me you're out
whatever that coping mechanism is that's
where i would deploy it and and i would
continue on the pattern now in a
conscious relationship the only thing
that makes it really different is that
when you hurt me
i'm able to sit with that and share what
hurt me and set a boundary if needed
and also
look within myself
and ask questions like what does this
represent for me right now what does
this feeling remind me of is there a
time when i was little where i remember
feeling this way
and and then i can go deeper and like
what is the fear underneath that
and then how can i share my need in a
way that you can now meet me so instead
of pushing love away i'm learning how to
work with what's coming up in me as a
way to bring me closer to you in
relationship and then also for some of
us who like to use spiritual language
you know closer to god or to source or
to higher power whatever do not gather
them at the top and i said why i said
i'm gathering there so i don't have to
make 15 trips and i know you want them
flat i don't have time and so i'm
putting him out and he's like no i need
you to hear me
i need you to stop doing it it's a major
boundary for me and then he explained
why which was super helpful yeah when i
see that tower of cardboard boxes
it makes me feel like you think i'm the
maid
[Music]
it makes me think you're stacking that
there
for
me to take care
of and
it makes me
feel
like you don't care about me
and when you explain it that way i'm
like oh my god no prob there will never
be another box here and there hasn't
been because i
understand
yeah
what he's working on and why this is
important and he incorporated feelings
he actually knows how he feels and he's
communicating it and communication is
the most important thing
[Music]